Alfonzo Caretti you girls been very busy  honey Ruby  [Music]  mrs. Brennan I won't fight Claire you're  the one I have to watch out for out here  [Music]  my husband's at 24 more months left  other services you girls gonna be just  fully we're gonna take care of you I  can't even make the rent what they gave  me last night what am I gonna do all  these men working these streets and not  a solid set of balls in here a bunch of  guys that don't even remember what  family means so we remind them I don't  want you to talk I want you to teach me  step off my business  it's my business now and if you need to  talk to [ __ ] through thing get out of  our way I know their rights to wipe you  off the face of the earth we've worked  hard for this you want to go back to how  it was I'd rather die than go back  you go to war there's no coming back  Claire put a bullet in his head you  girls kill me  [Music]  you  you